من المطاعم الصاخبة
إلى الشواطئ المزدحمة
[الموسيقى]
يبدو أنه
ليس حتى في الوباء على الرغم من أن
الجميع يرتدون قناعًا ولكني
أشعر حقًا أننا
نعود إلى الوضع الطبيعي
بينما يغلق متغير
omicron البلدان حول الأرقام القياسية العالمية
من السائحين والزوار
يتدفقون على دبي في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
في برج خليفة ،
تستعد فرق المباني الأطول
في العالم لعرض الألعاب النارية وضوء الليزر ،
دبي لا تفعل شيئًا بسيطًا
هذا العام سيحتاج المحتفلون عشية العام الجديد
إلى التسجيل عبر  تطبيق
للوصول لمشاهدة العرض ، وسط مدينة دبي ،
خذ نفساً عميقاً مدفوعًا بواحد من
أعلى معدلات التطعيم في العالم
والتفويضات الحكومية الصارمة ، أصبحت دبي
نقطة جذب سياحي نحن
هنا في الوباء ، فهناك الكثير من
الناس هنا  نعلم لكننا نحن
أقنعة ولدينا جواز سفر تغطية
وكل ذلك
[موسيقى]
حسب دائرة
السياحة بدبي يصل الزوار الدوليون  سجلت
أكثر من مليون شخص في فنادق أكتوبر في
دبي زيادة بنسبة 16.8 في الإشغال
في الأشهر العشرة الأولى من عام 2021.
وقد أفادت الإمارات العربية المتحدة أن 99 من جميع
المؤهلين للحصول على اللقاحات ، أي شخص يزيد عمره عن
12 عامًا قد تلقى جرعة واحدة على الأقل ،
وسوف تشعر بأي ألم.
أنا مندهش حقًا لأنني وجدت
الكثير من الأشخاص هنا ،
لذا فأنا لست خائفًا قليلاً من
الاختبار إيجابيًا هنا ،
لكن دعونا نأمل ألا تكون
استضافة المعرض العالمي بمثابة نقطة
جذب لدبي هذا العام ، حيث
تجاوزت الزيارات 6.3 مليون.  اعتبارًا
من منتصف ديسمبر
ولكن مع استمرار الحفلة في دبي
حيث يتجول العالم في وجهة السفر الفاخرة هذه ، ستستمر هذه الوجهة الفاخرة في
المضي
قدمًا وكما يقولون يجب أن يستمر العرض